good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press in
public I welcome you to the meeting of
the council this evening housekeeping if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security or opposite in the
lifts in the Fourier please do not use
the lifts please assemble in holy square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber I can confirm that
the Proceedings of this meeting will be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the Internet I would advise that if
filming takes place anyone in attendance
in the public areas may have then the
image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present there's anyone intend to film
the meeting this evening thank you in
that case if any member of the public
who objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meeting you can ask
everyone present to please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst the
meeting is in progress you can now move
on to the agenda proper and the agenda
item one is apologies for absence
apologists have been received from
councillors Constantine and Dixon are
there any other apologies for the
meeting this evening council farewells
generalizing two minutes of the previous
meeting held on the 28th February 2019 I
move that the minutes of the meeting of
the Council held on the 28th of February
2019 be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chairman please
second a second chair do members agree
thank you
gender item three announcements I have
not been informed of any announcements
for this evening so agenda item four
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest councillor
campbell a probably counselor allowance
scheme I think we're all interested
there army or disinterested which
everyone is I'll pass across to my
colleague thank you very much chairman
yes all members have a general
dispensation in place regarding matters
relating to members allowances thank you
agenda item five petitions to petitions
have been received in accordance with
council procedure number twelve with
members please note that the first
petition agenda item 5a regarding
modern-day slavery has been withdrawn at
the request of the petition organizer so
we can move on to agenda item 5b
petition regarding the budget an e
petition containing 37 valid signatures
has been received by the council I'm
pleased to welcome mr. Finnegan to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for a
report to the council within three
ordinary meetings general item six
questions from the press and public one
question has been received from the
member of the public in accordance with
council procedure rule number 13 please
note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question and that if the questioner is
not present at this meeting their
question cannot be put that will be
replied to in writing could the
questioner please only state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
objection their question is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they submitted the council
so agenda item six a question from a
member of the public regarding clean
streets and highways with members please
refer to supplementary agenda one and I
am pleased to welcome mr. Weiss to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table please mr. Weiss
okay Thank You mr. chairman
my question is addressed to Council a
savage cabinet member for operational
services question is the basic
competence of the council can be
measured in its ability to keep streets
and highways free from litter and other
detritus to its shame
Thanet council failed spectacularly in
this regard and shames us all what are
you going to do about it
residents and visitors deserve better
Thank You mr. wires
I call upon councillor savage to respond
Thank You chairman I'm delighted not to
receive this question and to answer it
jaren I am approaching the end of my
short tenure as portfolio holder of
operational services and this question
enables me to give counts or something
of a report of the issues and problems
that I have faced in my time here it is
with sadness I must report the following
enforcement actions over the last year
this council has issued the following
penalties to deal with litter and
rubbish offenses 69 fixed penalty
notices of 400 pounds for fly-tipping
and dumping the successful prosecution
of over 25 people in the magistrate's
court there have been a further 67
prosecutions in a magistrate's court for
non-payment or fixed penalty notices
furthermore this council enforcement
services has issued the following
enforcement notices to deal with litter
and rubbish offenses 190 pest damage by
rubbish notices no less than 772
environmental protection at section 46
notices 60 commercial trade waste
notices 107 community protection
warnings for litter and waste offences
20 community protection notices with a
hundred pound fines for litter and waste
offences and finally this
has undertaken no less than and I say
this twice 3755 3755 enforcement litter
and waste investigations now to
performance over the last 12 months our
clearing teams have collected 900 tons
from public litter bins collected 840
tons or Street sweepings collected over
a hundred tons of fly-tipping x' and
finally collected no less than 3,500
tons of litter from our beaches now to
improvement so a litter collection in
2017 performance stood as 17% of streets
with litter at an unacceptable level in
2019 our performance is now at 10% with
respect to detritus which mr. wises
specifically mentions in 2017
performance was 21.9% of streets with an
unacceptable level now in 2019
performance is now at 5.1 percent lower
than our target at 7 percent it is
getting dark out there now and from my
experience over the last 6 months
someone somewhere is about to chuck a
bag of mixed rubbish out into the street
elsewhere someone's going to leave a
mattress propped up against a wall an
old sofa has suddenly materialized on a
grass verge someone driving on the sub
Peters Road at speed is about to empty
the litter in their car out of the
window personal experience I've
witnessed it and tomorrow morning I'll
get the email complaints where is this
correct
when is this council game to clear up
I'm afraid the facts bit are there and
the conclusion is obvious I'll tell you
what is shameful mr. wise the fact that
we have visitors and some of our own
residents who litter and fly tip our
streets the fact we have had to impose
so many fines and prosecution's of some
of our own residents and visitors that
is the true
shame mr. wise I'm going to step game to
take a step further now appraising the
efforts of our frontline staff who have
to deal on a daily basis with a
continuous onslaught of mindless
littering and fly-tipping of
congratulating the managers for
motivating the staff and for
spearheading action finally of
considering it a privilege to work with
senior officers to do all that can be
done with the resources our disposal for
the benefit of our residents in
conclusion what I find very sad is I
feel this question is an attempt to
discredit the work of this council the
opportunity of a question to counter
should not be used to castigate the
cabinet member officers and frontline
staff on behalf of our hard-working
staff I strongly refute this questions
intrinsic accusation and in closing and
with your permission chairman I would
like a round of applause for our
frontline staff please could you support
me in that and all counselors could we
have a round of applause for our
frontline staff please Thank You
chairman Thank You councillor savage and
just within the three minutes and thank
you mr. wise for general items seven
questions from members of the council
one question has been received from
members of the council agenda item 7a
question number one from a member
regarding the funding of tourism
services I call upon counselor Johnson
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman I was considering withdrawing
this question but this evening I
received a substantial petition from
residents particularly in the Margate
area so I will continue with my question
if I may my question is this tourism is
one of the most important wealth and
well-being generators and thanat could
the cabinet member confirm she is
persuading colleagues to reverse the
allocation of 3 million pounds to this
building and using some of the monies to
save our vital tourism staff and
services transformation money
can be used in this way thank you I call
upon the leader to respond
counsel David yes Thank You chairman
thankfully question counselor junction
and I'm not counting for a speed okay um
I took it more than it was to do with
budget allocation so I've taken it on um
I've got to say that I was quite just
surprised really to see that after 24
years on this council you don't seem to
appreciate the difference between
revenue spend and capital expenditure
it does however give me the opportunity
to elaborate on why we have made the
provision of 3 million pounds for office
accommodation
Vanek District Council main offices were
built in the 1970s but almost 50 years
on the structure and services within the
building has started to show signs of
deterioration continuing to put off
addressing the issues with the building
when inevitably lead to even greater
costs further down the line I think it's
worth pointing out that council staff
numbers are virtually harmed in that
time period this provision of three
million pounds indicated in the budget
is just that it's a provision rather
than a confirmed total spend at this
stage we want to look at a range of
potential decisions regarding the office
building and this will include
undertaking a full independent
assessment of the most pragmatic options
available to the council this couldn't
mean move into a smaller space
refurbishing the existing space or a
combination of the two I think what's
missing from the published information
is the fact that if we refurbish this
building the running cost would be
reduced and surplus space could be let
bringing in additional income if the
council were to move they will clearly
be a capital receipt to offset the cost
of the new accommodation so to answer
your question counselor Johnson no one
is looking to reverse this decision and
even if they were monies could not be
redirected to me service costs Thank You
Cal sabay furred Kelso Johnson do you
have a supplementary question yes thank
you I do and I know that councillor
Beaufort's been here even
than myself and he must know that a
Conservative government has actually
allowed us to use capital for
transformation and there would be ways
around this and I have spoken to
officers within this council I'm
surprised you haven't done likewise it
was a Conservative government that gave
us that allowance however my further
question really is on this we have a
duty of care to all of our staff and I
understand that seven of our highly
valued tourism staff are at risk of
losing their jobs
I would ask as part of a duty of care of
every councillor and here to every
member of staff that we actually revisit
this we cannot replace valued paid staff
with volunteers the tourism staff do an
amazing job they advise on coastal
safety they talk and speak to our gather
nearly ninety nine thousand people in
the last year eighty two thousand that
have been footfall in to the Droid shows
and the tourism points so I'm asking
please what effort has been made to
redeploy those seven staff that I'm
talking about
that we all every one of us have a duty
of care to we have a duty of care when
people are reported to standards who
have upset staff we have a duty of care
to staff who are also at a lower
employment level thank you Thank You
councillor Johnson I don't personally
feel it's appropriate for the leader to
respond but he's ready to respond if
you'd like councillor David these are
staff matters and I'm not sure that you
we should be discussing them in open
forum no I won't talk about staff
matters but I would like to say that
tourism is an integral part of our
ongoing successes of destination we're
currently in the process of reviewing
how we will continue to deliver this in
the future to ensure that this remains a
successful part of our local economy
this is in the wider context of the
council facing serious financial
pressures thank you thank you council
benefit agenda item 8 motions of notice
no motions of notice have been received
in accordance with council procedure
rule 3 so agenda item 9 leaders report I
call upon the leader
Thank You German I'm sure that everyone
is aware of the plan to use Menston as a
lorry part for up to six and a half
thousand trucks in the event of a
buildup of traffic due to delays at
Dover / post bricks it whenever post
brexit or if post bricks here or
whatever bricks it may be this would be
in conjunction with the deployment of
Operation Brock on the m20 Brock would
facilitate around 2,000 vehicles
crawling towards Dover with any excess
traffic being diverted to Menston to be
held prior to being drip fed to Dover
along the a2 five six I have a great
concern that this could lead to chthonic
being effectively cut off from the rest
of King a situation which would be
exacerbated in the event of accidents or
breakdowns on the a2 five six and a
failure of involved enforcement which
could mean that
HGVs find themselves in appropriate
places adding to the chaos I on the
senior management team believed that
this scheme is all conceived and will
lead to considerable disruption for the
residents of Thanet we feel that there
was some logic when consideration was
being given to using ramsgate as a port
of exit but that it doesn't work just as
a facility for the Port of Dover TDC
does not support operation Brock but
despite this your offer but your
officers are working with partner
agencies to ensure that should match
them be called in to use the situation
won't be managed as effectively as
possible to reduce the impact on the
local community it should be borne in
mind that the situation is intended to
be temporary and any inconvenience
should be short-lived
we'll wait and see on police report that
CDC is sending an expression of interest
in a share of the future high streets
fund which will provide Co funding
towards capital projects that could
bring about transformational change to a
town centre as each council could put
forward just one request we were in the
invidious position of having to choose
which of our high streets should go
forward to this end a cross-party cross
town working party was set up to decide
which ones should be supported in the
end it was a close call between Margate
and round
guy with Ramsgate being the final choice
Browns got has seen little investment in
recent years and has repeatedly suffered
filed or stalled developments the town
has a significant case to make in terms
of its social and economic needs as well
as its physical regeneration needs the
scale of need an opportunity to deliver
change was compared across the three
main towns and Ramsgate was identified
as having the most potential I have to
say that Margate was a close second
and should the Ramsgate bid be
unsuccessful will be the subject of an
application in a future second round of
bidding whilst on the topic of funding
we've received two payments from the
government towards the cost incurred as
a result of brexit one of 35,000 which
was given to all District Council's and
another of a hundred and thirty six
thousand which was given to any district
with the port we've also been successful
in a bid to the coastal revival fund for
forty four thousand to commissioned a
feasibility and option study in respect
of the ligth oh and Clifton Barnes site
this could provide the public with an
opportunity to access this iconic
Margate location for the first time in
over 40 years a very pleasing aspects of
this bid was the way the local community
organizations and businesses
enthusiastically gave their support and
I'm sure this contributed to its success
councillor savages earlier answer
covered many points about litter but I
want to point out the businesses that
use public litter bins or slighted their
commercial waste are actually breaking
the law this contributes to overflowing
litter bins and creates litter across
our streets and open spaces most
businesses comply with the law but TDC
has recently sent notices to 90
businesses who presently fail to comply
as a result they're now planning to
dispose of their waste correctly and
have trade waste agreements in place our
enforcement teams have been visiting
businesses to ensure that they have
agreements in place this council has
been said by counsel Savage is often
criticized over the state of some of its
streets but again as he said it's the
public who create the mess and in some
areas
keeping them clean is an uphill battle
they must be extremely dispiriting to
staff that there is rarely any prize
given for the many areas that are always
kept clean and rubbish free and there
are a lot of them in the district I can
also announce that we've introduced the
rogue landlord scheme whereby landlords
are set to face penalties up to 30,000
if they are found thirty thousand pounds
if they're found contravening housing
law the end of this is to help protect
residents health and safety and will be
I'm also pleased to report the penny
button council is Lee game gave a
presentation to the LGA on social
integration and cohesion and that the
LGA are now using this in their new
cohesion guidance this is a tremendous
accolade for a Community Safety Team
we're also setting up a cabinet advisory
group on health and well-being to advise
on issues regarding the East Kent
Hospital trust and the effects of any
change there on our residents on a
property front we've negotiated the
sound of pre freehold loans from our vet
Football Club which will enable them to
finance the development of the ground to
ensure their sustainability as a
successful Football Club well into the
future
we've also facilitated the style of the
Ramsgate sands or is it royal sales site
to blueberry homes in order to guarantee
the development of the site in the near
future it's also pleasing to note that
almost three million pounds has been
realized this year from the sound of
council properties which were surplus to
requirements and this money will help to
fund other projects for the benefit of
our residents it wasn't in my report and
I do apologize to the other leaders but
I think it's also worth pointing out
that Marga has been selected to house
the blue flag Awards in May which I
think is a tremendous accolade for us
and is richly deserved probably because
we've got more blue flags than most
other places as this is the last leaders
report of this council cycle I would
like to take this opportunity to thank
the senior management team for the help
and support they've given me in my
cabinet over the past year I would also
like to record my appreciation of our
hard-working staff for the service they
give to the people of Planet making the
best use of the diminishing resources
that are at their disposal whilst
receiving very
thanks in return Thank You chairman
thank accounts of a furred
I call upon councillor Wells to comment
on or ask questions in relationship to
the leaders report and before you start
councillor Wells I've received your note
and I was going to mention it at the end
of the meeting because there more than
one reciprocal councillor world thank
you
become the custom I suppose with council
abatage reports and it's more about what
he doesn't say that what he does say and
it is quite interesting to run through
some elements of that report and what
was said but what perhaps the
counterbalance was in other areas he he
makes great play of getting two hundred
and fifty three hundred thousand pounds
back from various government funds but
I'm very first two serious financial
difficulties but omits to mention it is
the austerity decisions made by the
conservative governments of recent years
that means we are looking at scams like
six council world I don't think we need
to go into showboating political
statements a mr. chairman
six million pounds less in our budget
twenty two and a half million down to 16
and a half next year because of that
austerity policy it is something that
perhaps he could in all honesty I've
actually talked about as well in exactly
the same vein I think new esta to
remember that actually the battle for
how that high street in Ramsgate and
Margate was one was rather more fearsome
than perhaps he gave reference to and
certainly I think members who were
representing Ramsgate felt that they
were disadvantaged in that battle from
the very beginning and we're very
pleased it came across the round
scheduling at something from this
particular application and that's
actually very good to see there's on the
opening paragraphs all about operation
brach and Briggs it or whatever I don't
know about anybody else in this room but
I'll have to say that you know even as
anoraks
and get to the point I suspect we're
we're bored with this god only knows
what ordinary people in the street
actually think of this particular mess
and and it just be holds I think
for behaves all of us to think very
carefully about the logic behind some of
the things that we actually undertake in
the name of our residents and for me and
there was reference chairs where the
most significant emission from Karis
labayda's report and it was good to hear
it actually dealt with because we had a
bit of vintage Irish before he started
that actually both counts the bill
heightened that in Cancellara's Johnson
are I believe standing down this time
and our councillors of very long
standing in this place almost pillars of
the institution and I do think given
that we talked about giving members of
staff around of applause and giving all
sort of hollaby perón of course both of
them and let it be said I'd haven't
always agreed with them I haven't always
agree with them but both of them both of
them have actually given very long
service this council and to their
residents and I do think the leader
perhaps should have mentioned that but
perhaps we could give them a round of
applause
cancel basis you have the opportunity to
respond issue which yeah Thank You
chairman in response to the last bit I
mean I think the agenda item says that I
can report on things that have happened
since our last meeting well to my best
of my knowledge counseling
mrs. Johnson against the heightened I
haven't left yet so it would have been a
bit premature and and I've also got a
site either as counsel Johnson is
concerned I'm still waiting for the
third of April to make sure she really
is going you know well I'm sure as it's
election time you were bound to make
mention of the government I'm not going
to comment on that I did say at the last
meeting with that you weren't at that
unfortunately the Chancellor doesn't win
me only a Secretary of State for
Transport brings me and asked my views
about things but if if the Chancellor
had private then I'll pass your thoughts
on castor oil don't worry about that and
as far as around it only I think it's a
bit of a shine that you sort of have to
be a bit bitter and twisted about the
Ramsgate High Street fund because in
fact we carried out a process and we got
the result we got it was it was carried
out in an objective fashion and I think
credit has to go to accounts the linphea
brass because she put up a very spirited
aren't safe fight because that's not the
right way although it has to be said
that the meters we had a think is fair
so we'll robust but then out of those
kind of meetings you get the best
decisions and that's what happened as
far as people's well their patients
progress I think you're right I think
it's running out I think patients with
politicians is running out and my fear
for this current election is that apathy
will rule and the turnout will be very
low and I think that's a shame because
what happens here whilst it's affected
by what happens in Westminster you know
to local people it's more important than
I should take an interest thank you
thankfully counsel of a furred I call
upon counselor revelant Piper to comment
on or ask questions in relationships of
the leaders report councillor Piper
Thank You mr. chairman
perhaps the one of the things we can do
as a council even in these last days of
the lifespan of this one is to actually
communicate much more frequently and
much better with the members of the
public that an apathy really wouldn't be
a problem I feel absolutely certain
about that but thank you for your report
leader I'm sure everyone here shares
your expressed concerns about the
potential difficulties for this district
if the government doesn't get its act
together and deal with brexit more
maturely operation brach cannot be seen
as a long-term solution and the
government appears to be spending
millions of pounds on short-term panic
measures despite having had two years to
make a plan perhaps they should have
left local people with local knowledge
to come up with a better local solution
drew Redskins will be delighted that
Ramsgate has been supported in the way
it has to benefit from additional monies
for the high street funds project
project and again thanks to Council in
February efforts Ramsgate councillors
have often voiced concerns that we are
the Forgotten member of the big three in
Thanet I know I've done it myself from
here several times fly-tipping is a
blight on our communities and I would
urge the new council to deal more
robustly with offenders including the
disgusting leavings of various traveler
communities who have blessed us with
their presence on numerous occasions how
they expect local residents to make them
feel welcome when they treat our open
spaces as they do is totally beyond me
there are other encouraging reports in
your report this evening leader the LGA
social integration of cohesin guidance
what a what a feather in the cap for
them that is the cabinet advisory group
on health and well-being the long
awaited eminent we hope development of
the royal sand site and the continuing
growth of Margate Football Club leader I
realized that we're not paying for the
feasibility study in respect of the lie
though and Clifton baths and welcome
that news as
I'm sure many members were rather hoping
for some details deceiving about the
promise feasibility study of Ramsgate
for there is none not even a start date
instead either we are treated to public
information which suggests not just
repairs to births four and five which is
actually what was approved by this
council if you read the words carefully
it says repairs were approved but not
just repaired we're creeping into
something that's irrelevant in
association with the leaders report
councillor Piper you're responding to
the leaders report and you're absolutely
right there was no mention of it so I'll
ask councillor Beaufort if he wishes to
respond but he's not obliged to carry on
Thank You mr. chairman we don't even
have a start day for that instead I
don't recall any of the details of this
development being shared with members of
just wondered whether they should have
been can you confirm that this rather
huge material change to the port will
not in any way undermine the promised
feasibility study to which this council
has already committed we're carrying on
their supply promissory point it would
be a lot wonderful legacy for this
administration as it shuts down to be
able to say to the people of Phoenix the
feasibility study is on its way
finally can the council please issue a
public statement about the works and the
reasons for them including
responsibility to pay for them and so on
because that information surely cannot
be a secret and it would help this
council not to receive so many of the
attacks it does in public places thank
you I agree with the attacks and thank
you I'll ask the leader if he wishes to
respond right well let's address the
feasibility study first I couldn't have
made it clearer I don't know how many
times this has come up I've made it
absolutely clear that this council is
committed to carrying out a feasibility
study and if you remember counselor
Pfeiffer in response to your request I'd
actually give an undertaking as far as I
can because there's nothing to say that
after my the the second it will be me
doing the talking but if we are back
here you have a commitment that that
feasibility study will be completed by
the end of the year and I think its
completion is much more relevant than
the start date what I would say is
partly in response to what you said in
partly in response to the noise that
there's been existing out there that as
far as I'm concerned the whatever is
happening to the birth that the bets on
the bridge key has got nothing to do
with the feasibility study other than
the fact that they'll be recognized that
it's there and it's in fact will be
taken into account what I would also
point out to you is that you know
there's a lot of fuss about this this is
actually been in the capital program I
think from memory for about four years I
think it was put in by a previous
administration of which you remember so
the specification of it would have been
down to you and your colleagues
councilor pipe so perhaps at some stage
you'd like to tell people if an it why
it's in there that would be very good
they're very useful I've taken two to
more positive things you talked about a
towns and you know the our attempt to
get money for round again you talk about
the big three I've gotta say that it's a
list of monies that come Broadstairs why
he was made really sure really really
sure we we sit back in in or that the
complaints that come from rounds gate
and Margit a bit hard done by they are
but that's another story to finish on a
very positive note what I can do is to
say that you know of course the traveler
situation is the problem it's been an
ongoing one we're very aware of it and I
do believe that particular thanks to the
activities councillor Ashby that we may
have some solutions on the horizon more
news on this later thank you
Thank You councillor David I now call
upon councillor metaphase to comment on
or ask questions in relationship to the
leaders report
Celso matter face Thank You chair I
promise I'm not going to ask too many
questions because I'm still waiting for
answers
some of the questions I put to you in
December the six so I can't hang around
waiting for the answers because I won't
be standing in May regarding the lorry
park could you give us some update of
how plans are progressing to keep fana
accessible because we've discussed
tourism we know how important to him is
tourism is and when operation Brock was
in place before we know it had a major
impact on accessibility to that it we're
getting 171,000 from the government and
I assume this would be used in part for
that perhaps mr. white can enlighten us
on that we've already had references to
litter my own personal observation is
that we do have bins which is great but
they're not emptied often enough
particularly in my local park and also I
think it's crucial that our roads and
pavements are swept occasionally there
are areas of Fallot that are extremely
windy and I get people telling me that
the red bag was put out is often
material is blown out of it and just
soft down the road and also with
interest the reference to the social
cohesion event that canceled the game
and Penny Buckner went to because I was
involved with extremely informative
session that took place at the gap
project in Broadstairs where the
research are working on exactly the same
and I am awaiting the final report from
her it was across religion across faiths
group and it was extremely informative
and everybody spoke very highly of
Fernet but they did appreciate there
were issues that needed looking at I'm
disappointed and I know I'm commenting
but I'm disappointed you've made no
reference to the bus service cuts that
are about to be introduced on the 7th of
April both your ward and my ward leader
are going to be severely affected by the
change from two buses an hour to one bus
an hour and the one bus are now will no
longer serve Broadstairs station
Broadstairs library or the Broadway
Medical Center because it will be taking
a completely different route and there
are also residents and other parts of
Broadstairs Brad
still Viking answered Peters whose bus
service is going to be reduced to
virtually nothing we're going to have a
lot of people who are going to become
very isolated and unable to access our
town centers or other parts of Thanet
Council metaphase interesting
information I listened and took it all
in but can we get back to the leaders
report please but I'm gonna win be
pleased to hear but I'd like to end I'd
like to thank everybody in the chamber
the officers and fellow councillors who
have been extremely helpful have worked
together with us over the last four
years and I wish everybody who is
standing again who's sitting in this
chamber all the best in the election and
as they say by the best man and woman
win thank you Thank You council matter
face council a foot response yeah I mean
I think most of that really doesn't
require comment for me particulars most
of it referred to a method outsider
absolutely the bus services I agree with
you but you know it's not a district
function so I don't feel that it's right
for me to be commenting on that what I
would say as far as the the litter is
concerned again that we are just about
to deploy 75 smart bins people don't
know what they are they're big bins
they've got technology inside and they
actually signal when they're reaching
fullness now big benefit of that is that
if it works properly they get emptied
before they overflow but perhaps just as
importantly they don't get emptied when
they're in sea because under current
system you know the bin and go around
and they actually all the bins where
they're stuffing them or not so there we
are but I agree with you in your
comments about we have people that are
moving on and so so thank you thank you
can say furred
we'll move on shall we
agenda item 10 annual report of the
chairman of the executive policy and
Community Safety scrutiny panel
I call upon council again Coleman cook
to present his report councillor Coleman
cook Thank You mr. chairman I'd like to
take this opportunity to thank the
members of the executive scrutiny panel
for their contributions to the work of
the panel throughout the year and the
cabinet for accepting various
invitations to our meetings and to
responding to questions from members
the most significant review carried out
by the panel was the reviewing of the
proposed draft local development plan
upon invitation to consider the cabinet
proposals for the new plan I was pleased
and I think so with the other panel
members when some of our recommendations
were endorsed by cabinets and full
council as detailed in the report before
you I look forward to the final outcome
after all the consultations have been
done the panel also made suggestions to
the council such as continuing
supporting local museums and cameras
firm they would take note of our
recommendations if they decide to
proceed with marketing accounts
properties in question we also received
very informative presentation on the
work of operational services it was
especially pleasing to note the hard
work put into the various aspects of the
service by officers particularly in
enforcement we reviewed the impact of
the new public spaces protection order
that was applied to some walls in
Margate and Ramsgate although we did not
get the full picture of the
effectiveness of the order the exercise
was worthwhile as this inform members on
how this was panning out additional
reviews will be required and a final
review of this order will be undertaken
once the implementation period has ended
finally I'd like to report the panel
also called in the executive decision on
digital parking because it did not
provide sufficient information support
the decision made however after some
debate that involved the leader standing
in for the portfolio holder the panel
was satisfied with the additional
information provided and no further
action was required in conclusion I'd
like to thank all the officers who
provided support to the work of the
panel throughout the year it was my
pleasure to be part of this committee
and I'm grateful for the opportunity I
had services chairman and now now I
might members to comment on the report
thank you
Thank You counselor Coleman cook any
questions or comments in that case thank
you again we can move on to agenda item
11 which is the annual report of the
chairman of the finance budget and
performance scrutiny panel I call upon
councilor Linda Piper to present her
report
Piper Thank You members before I briefly
outlining the work done by this panel
since its inception I would like to
thank mr. Charles hyung wait Nick Hughes
and the team who have worked so hard to
support us and deliver the presentations
we have sought this report tonight is a
summary of our activities on your behalf
it notes cabinet member presentations as
well as officer presentations to the
panel it has been a pleasure to hear
from members regarding issues such as
the port of Ramsgate fees and charges in
the forward plan as well as questions
concerning temporary accommodation and
homeless households it is widely
accepted that the rollout of universal
credit has not gone as smoothly as we
was originally intended and is having an
adverse impact on households ability to
pay rent as the report highlights
against these challenges the
homelessness team have prevented 213
households from becoming homeless to the
period ending September 2018 compared to
92 in the same period during 2017 there
is no doubt that the demand for housing
and homelessness intervention is rising
and our team deserve our congratulations
for all their efforts more details about
the committee's role are noted in annex
1 on pages 40 and 41 members it has been
a privilege and a pleasure to serve as
chairman of this committee and I commend
this report to you thank you mrs. Jenna
Thank You councillor Kelso Johnson did I
see your hand go up I'm delighted you
saw my hand going up thank you thank you
for everybody for your kind applause
earlier on but I have a question on
your report counselor under two cabinet
member presentations of panel meetings
under a point about presentation on
Ramsgate port and harbor the leader
promised you that evening under 2.2 in
concluding the debate the leader of
council committed to finding a way to
improve the operations at the port and
would also be improving the
communication of messages relating to
the port and harbor did he tell you that
evening that Mr grayling had never even
contacted Seaborn or in fact the ocular
company by the way I went to school with
the families from Arklow the currents
and materials so I know a little bit
about the background to all of this did
the leader tell you that Mr grayling had
never even contacted those companies
vintage boys council councillor Piper
are you able to respond no I was not
told by the leader that was grayling
hadn't contacted us I think perhaps this
question would be better dealt with by
the leader myself I think it's very hot
news that became public today even
didn't it so well read councillor
Johnson can we move on Thank You general
item 12 annual report of the chairman of
the governance and Audit Committee
I call upon counts a day to present his
report Council a day thank you on an
annual basis the governance and Audit
Committee go through a self-assessment
process to understand its performance
against the terms of reference this
information then feeds into the annual
report which is before you all this
evening the annual report provides
details of attendance of meetings and
reports considered by the committee and
the outcome of the self-assessment it
also identifies any future challenges
for the committee and actions to improve
its effectiveness I therefore propose
that members note the content of the
annual report and actions within the
action plan I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank the members of the
governance and Audit Committee for
the contribution and also thank the
officers who have supported the work of
the committee
throughout the municipal year thank you
very much Thank You Cal today questions
comments in that case we can move on to
agenda item 13 which is the annual
report of the independent chairman of
the Standards Committee I call upon dr.
sexton to present his report dr. sexton
could you please make your way to the
top table thank you
dr. Sexton Thank You chairman members
will have read the report and reflected
on its contents I therefore I'm not
intending to present it or go into any
further detail I invite any questions
should there be any but otherwise invite
you to notice the contents of this
report for this year thank you thank you
questions councillor Piper Thank You mr.
chairman and thank you to dr. Saxon for
the work that he's done for many years
now for this council mr. chairman I
don't paragraph 4.3 on page 69 of this
agenda item and in particular take note
of the suggestion of a significant delay
in the performance of the committee's
duties if counsel fails to appoint this
evening so I'd like your permission to
speak when we get to the next item
agenda because I think it refers to dr.
Saxons position thank you I don't feel
it's appropriate at this point because
we move on to agenda item 14 thank you
dr. sexton
agenda item 14 appointment of
independent members of the standards
committee and independent persons I move
that the council approved the
appointment of dr. Sexton as an
independent member of the Standards
Committee until the 2020 annual council
meeting with the vice chairman please
second second chair do members agree
sorry
councillor Piper can I hold that
question back thank you Thank You
chairman I was a bit quick on my feet
earlier my apologies perhaps I should
repeat a note paragraph 4.3 on page 69
and take note of suggestion of a
significant delay in the performance of
the committee's duties if counsel fails
to appoint this evening I'd like to
challenge that assertion and offer a
better way forward mr. chairman I've
done a little research and discovered
that during the lifetime of this council
session just about four years forty-one
percent of all the standards committee
meetings have been canceled that's
almost half there go the committee is
actually not that busy
which might prompt a question do we
really need it elected members are there
only people who have to abide by the set
standards of behavior on that committee
and it seems bizarre to me that neither
officers nor even the independently
appointed persons come under the remit
of the very committee that they run I
would suggest that instead of focusing
entirely on the behavior of members the
committee should also scrutinize when
necessary
any officer behavior which may be
questioned even and especially to
exonerate them at times if necessary
counts the piper
Officer Tim Howells would like to
intervene can mr. house respond when I
finished then he'll know what I'm going
to say otherwise he's guessing
thank you thank you chairman the first
point I make is that while standards
committee has not met as often as it
could even it only met when those
relevant visits the main part of its
business is of course dearly complaints
against councillors in them in the
hearing subcommittees and hearing
assessment subcommittees and dealing
with investigations that's the principal
part of its work and those reports and
the results of that work is reported to
some committee in any event in terms of
law the committee can only deal with
complaints against members and that's
what it's there for we've set up on the
Localism Act for that particular purpose
it has no power to deal with complaints
against officers and nor should it
because officers who bought bound by a
contract of employment with their own
rules but discipline and performance and
it be wholly inappropriate for members
to get involved in that process at that
stage thank you thank you is is it a
probe here I've got councillor Johnson
wants to speak and councillor Hazen can
you sum up I count them up quickly thank
you for that additional information you
guess well rather than a point post this
evening I would like to propose that
this vote is delayed until the summer to
give the incoming members of the new
council an opportunity to have a
meaningful vote on the interested
candidates having first reviewed that
suggested officer submissions this would
give them plenty of time by delaying the
appointment until the summer mr.
chairman the committee will only have
missed one meeting and there's half a
chance
well 41% chance that meeting would be
canceled anyway so I'd like to make that
proposal mr. chairman that we delay the
vote until the summer when we can have a
meaningful vote involving the new
members of this chamber mr. house to
comment I will get to council Johnson
and councillor Hazen but mr. Hills first
I think the two issues the first things
the
work is ongoing there are already
complaints in train and currently under
invest in the potential investigation
and therefore to have no committee at
all would mean we couldn't actually
carry out any standards work during that
time and I think that being in breach of
the Localism Act to do that second issue
is your proposal just seem to be a
direct opposite of what's being proposed
and therefore you could achieve the same
result by voting against the appointment
councillor Johnson you were next thank
you very much chairman actually there is
a whole recommendation here one for it
was kind of implied in your words that
it was just dr. Sexton and mrs. bacon in
fact there are four names here and so I
would like to support the recommendation
very much for the reasons mr. house gave
an awful lot of the work that we do on
standards those of us who are on various
panels and volunteer to be on panels is
way outside what you would know as
normal meetings standards meetings have
been canceled that's for sure but
there's an awful lot of work that we do
I know that comes from McDonough
Anderson and I are often on panels and
we have to be so independent minded
particularly if it's someone of our own
political persuasion I'm grateful to dr.
Sexton mrs. bacon and mr. James and mr.
Tucker and all who come to our meetings
and all who support us
I wouldn't always agree with everything
but it is a very difficult task and as I
say when you go in that door to make
decisions on really your colleagues it
is often one where you really have to
have a total conscience on what you do
so I'm actually supporting the
recommendations you can't be without
these lead people in these meetings work
in this council continuous whether we're
here or not actually thank you Thank You
councillor Jonathan Kelso Hayden thank
you very much chairman and thank you all
for your kind regards to mind leaving
I'm sure you're quite happy for me to
leave at bedtime yes chairman I was a
former member of the independent
committee it's a small committee but
it's worthwhile remembering there's not
just standards for it it's the
constitutional part of the of this
council
and in my time there was lots of changes
to the Constitution it was brought to
this full council and quite frankly to
do away with an independent and I can
certainly say of the two independent
members are fulfilled their duty to the
nth degree and quite frankly I thank
them also thank you Thank You counsel
and councillor Johnson's absolutely
right there are more than one name
within this agenda item so I've moved
with regards to dr. Sexton Vice Chair
has seconded so I'm now asking do
members agree do you want to show her
hands on that counts the Piper in that
case all those members that agree with
the appointment please show hands now
I think well if I can if okay in that
case this is to approve the appointment
of dr. Sexton as an independent member
of the status committee until the 2020
annual council meeting all those members
had agree to approve and a point
dr. Sexton I'm doing them individually
if I may say so I think you know we all
have lots of issues with with the
independence does with you or not but I
do think it's invidious to separate the
four members of the committee in this
individual way and I do think but first
if if I was in your shoes I'd be putting
it as a hole first and if that fails
then you can go back the other I think
you know realistically you should put it
as a hole first I'll get I'll get mr.
house to explain that I do have
individual questions in my hand and each
one I'm told has to be appointed
individually cancer mr. Hales that
that's quite right chair and we are also
the middle of a vote anyway so yes you
have started that process so can I do it
again all those
[Music]
I don't think this I think a shower
hands cancer Johnson if I do it on one
I'll have to do it on all four so show
of hands to approve the appointment to
dr. Sexton as an independent member of
the standards committee until the 2020
annual council meeting all those in
favor
all those against abstentions
it's carried and dr. Sexton is approved
to the appointment independent member I
move on to the next item in my list on
my script as people know that I do
receive a script and that is I move that
the council approve the appointment of
mrs. bacon as an independent member of
the standards committee until the 2020
annual council meeting with the vice
chairman please second a second chair
thank you do members want to vote on
this or do members agree thank you I
move on I move that the council approve
the appointment of mr. James is
independent person until the 2020 annual
council meeting with the vice chairman
please second second chair do members
agree finally on this item I move that
the council approve the appointment with
mr. Tucker as deputy independent person
until the 2020 annual council meeting
with the vice chairman please second
second chair do members agree Thank You
general item 15 constitutional change
mandatory training I move that the
recommendations as South set out in the
report be adopted with the vice chairman
please second second chair do members
agree thank you
of course we're agreeing for the new
council of course counselor matter face
I just want to give as a member of the
member training group since it was set
up and we have had wanted to change us
your very circumstances but I would like
to thank the counselors who served on
that that members training day and also
mr. Hughes mr. Watson who have been
excellent clerical dentists on our toes
and it was pleasure to be on a committee
that was informal but where everybody's
views were taken into account so I just
like that recorded thank you thank you
council matter face
agenda item 16 the calendar of meetings
I move that the recommendation has set
out in the report be adopted with the
vice chairman please second second chair
do members agree Thank You general item
17 members allowances this is a report
back from the ekj IRP committee I move
that the report be noted with the vice
chairman please second second chair do
members agree Thank You general item 18
Ramsgate charities nominations I move
that the recommendations as set out in
the report be adopted with the vice
chairman please second secretary the
members agree thank you and finally on
the agendas agenda item 19 change of
polling places for the 2019 district
elections with members please note that
this report is for information only
thank you very much and before I cancel
metaphase yes I would like it recorded
that I'm straight I mean I have been in
touch with the chief executive and I am
aware of the history behind this but I
would like it recorded I'm very
disappointed that the only polling
station in beacon rod Ward is going to
be the easternmost part of the Ward
which is quite quite a walk for people
who live on the west and was part of the
ward
I appreciate the circumstances the
council had very little notice that the
church that was being used it was closed
and I also appreciate that efforts were
made to find an alternative but I would
like an assurance that if we do have a
snap general election or we even have
new elections or even a by-election who
knows that a second polling station will
be sought even if it's just a tenth on
west of a garden screen thank you thank
you and on that very subject I would
they'd like to apologize in some
respects to the residents of my ward
Viking wold unfortunately Broadstairs
and Sand Peters town counts who are
doing extensive refurbishment work at
Piermont Hall which means that the
polling station for that area of the
Viking ward has now been moved to Queens
Road and I've already received a number
of comments with regards to the lack of
parking but hopefully people will be
able to exercise and get some benefit
from it before we close the meeting I
would personally and I would ask all
members to acknowledge the sterling work
that has been carried out by
particularly councillor johnson and
councillor Hayden I have to say that
counts the hatin for counselor Mays
Saunders and myself was a mentor when we
first entered into local politics and I
served alongside councilor hatin in Brad
Stowe Ward for a term and found it very
educational and met with him on many
occasions when he was chairman of Kent
County Council and we were both
surrounded with bling my bling was
slightly better than here such as mayor
of Broadstairs Anson Peters and
councillor Johnson who has shown me in
many respects how to work and work well
within your elected Ward but I'd also
like to say to all members who are not
standing next time thank you for the
sterling work that you've done over the
last four years and for those that are
standing let's have as they say a clean
will functioned local election and
hopefully I'll see many of you not
necessarily sitting in this chair once
we reform after the election thank you
very much thank you
here endeth the lesson and here endeth
the meeting thank you very much